hey guys it's alex with all cars keep
programming and all cars brotherhood uh
today we're gonna be uh adding a key for
a 21 jeep wrangler
and uh the cool thing about this one or
different thing about this jeep wrangler
it's the all-electric
uh it's an electric um wrangler um it
still takes the same uh smart key
uh so we're gonna go ahead and use the
auto pro pad i'll see you guys inside
all right guys as you can see it's the
uh
five of
21 um and uh
see how you have different uh
different settings for the fuel door
hybrid electric
and then e-save okay
um
i'm gonna go ahead and show you guys
where to plug in it's not going to be at
the obd2
area
we're going to plug in over in the glove
box area on the right side of the
passenger side so i'm going to show you
guys that now
there's the original key there
you guys can see here
this doesn't work
so that's the plug-in area right there
you got to just pull the glove box down
you'll see the plug
i like to plug in
um right there
and uh i'll show you guys
like i said we're adding this key in
all right
all right guys i made sure that i was
plugged in
um
uh plugged into the internet all right
so just reset it on me
i'm just gonna go ahead and uh we're
gonna
go to emo shoot sorry it's moving
all right
chrysler jeep dodge
uh what i did was i went to
automatically identify make sure the
hazard lights are all hazards on so that
way the bcm's on and you can uh pull the
pin
and obviously auto detect
the vehicle
all right so you see 21 wrangler
and press yes it talks about the 12
the uh
gateway plug
all right so i'm going to go to read
security code
it says we must be online let's press ok
and go from there
all right so
let me go ahead and
okay so we got the access code 35634
and go add smart key turn hazards on
and already populated the passcode there
it's gonna tell me to place the key uh i
like to do the part
like right where the key fold is okay
i'm gonna go ahead and press that
press it against the
smart key
or against this uh start button
and just hold it there
said program failed in one second just
make sure
yep
try that one more time
hold it with the my right hand this time
let me go ahead and add it again
just uh
see i'm going to go ahead and grab that
press it right to there
and then see what happens
program success
all right so yeah i just kind of delayed
a little bit on putting to the button so
you can now see a number of keys and you
see there's three
i'm going to go ahead and uh turn off
the hazards now and
it should work
all right guys well
uh again this is alex with all cars keep
programming all cars brotherhood if you
guys learned anything uh share it uh
follow me and uh if you guys have any
suggestions please um let me know in the
comment section alright we'll see on the
next one guys